Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us on our first episode.
On the first official episode, right?
Thank you for the BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Well, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, Monday.
AKA FUWAMOCO.
And hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start off your day on the right paw.
Please make sure to tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING.
FUWAMOCO Morning.
Right above us.
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Well, maybe we'll jump right into things.
What's this?
We just reached 700,000 views on our cover of Kaibutsu!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
I'm really really happy that you have been enjoying it so much.
Do you have any favorite parts?
Moco-chan, do you have a favorite part?
I like the beginning too.
The beginning?
There's a part in the very very beginning, Moco-chan, that you sing, that your voice gets all like... I like that part.
What part is that?
Subarashiki Sekai.
I'm not too sure.
You have to listen closely, Ruffians.
It'll be in the first couple seconds.
We've seen in the comments that a lot of listeners seem to hear Marine-senpai.
Marine-senpai... Last time I checked, she's... She's not part of FUWAMOCO.
Unfortunately, she's not.
But it makes us happy that you would compliment us that way because we very much love Marine-senpai and Marine-senpai's voice.
Big compliment.
She wants to apply!
What would her name be?
I don't know if Rui-senpai would be okay with that.
But would you like to hear more songs?
More cover songs from us?
What would you like to hear?
There's a lot of really good songs so it's hard to decide.
Actually, it did take us quite a while to decide which song we wanted to pick for our very first cover.
It's difficult, you know?
There's so many good songs.
Right, you know?
And they can show all different types of you, so, you know?
There's those kind of ways to enjoy it too.
300 of them.
Aero by YOASOBI-san.
Are we gonna be stuck just to YOASOBI-san?
That's not too bad though, Aero.
Ah, Tuning Love.
Tuning Love's cute too.
Lots of good suggestions.
Kagamine Twins.
We definitely didn't have that thought too.
But thank you so much for listening to it.
We hope that you continue to enjoy it more and more and more.
We can hit 1 million?
That would be a big team.
Big, big, big team.
Let's not get ahead of ourselves.
No, no, not yet.
Maybe we can in the future.
Thank you!
But next, there's been another misunderstanding.
Misunderstanding.
I wanted to say, so last FUWAMOCO Morning, everyone was discussing tomorrow.
And you know it.
I got confused.
Yeah, because there's a lot of things I don't understand.
But I feel like tomorrow isn't one of them.
I just thought that, you know, there's two popular movies right now.
So then I thought maybe it was something from that because there's like a lot of things I don't know.
And the senpai members have been sending us a lot of things I don't know.
So I thought, but maybe it's from the movies or maybe it was from Die Hard.
Since I've never seen that movie and people like it.
It seems sort of like something that would be in Die Hard.
But no, Moco-chan, you're just like, I don't know lots of things, so it's probably not that, right?
Right.
Obviously, we really like hololive, but it's very hard to know everything about hololive.
But yeah, this was one of them.
Actually, actually, we took the official hololive quiz, the hololive kente.
I'm not sure if you did it.
Unfortunately, you can't take it anymore.
The testing period is over.
But we wanted to share our scores with you, you know?
hololive ID Kenten, hololive English Kenten, hololive GP Kenten, even the GP one in Japanese too.
We passed!
The official test.
Official test, you know.
We were really nervous about it because they're really hard.
Really, really hard.
You know, we study up a lot.
Maybe we studied a bit too much.
But we figured, you know, this would be the least we could do.
And obviously, by no means does it mean that we know everything.
We don't know everything.
We don't know nothing.
We'd like to know more too, but we're also very forgetful puppies when we're under pressure.
So like, if you were to ask me, Fuwawa, what are you streaming next?
I'd be like, I don't know!
Right, right.
So we have to make notes sometimes.
Alright, so more puppies, thank you!
We're pleased, Moco-chan, we're pleased.
It was very fun though, but...
It reminded me of being back at Guard Dog Training, right?
Right.
It was tricky.
Tricky, tricky.
Definitely recommend if they do hololive Kensei the official quiz again.
Right!
You get your certification.
Certification.
Yeah.
But also, there's been another misunderstanding.
This time it wasn't Mococo.
It was me.
During our question and answer stream, I picked up a comment about Takenoko vs Kinoko, which is Takenoko's bamboo shoots and Kinoko's mushrooms.
I thought, you know, the yummiest ones are actual mushrooms and actual bamboo shoots.
Mushrooms are very very yummy.
But what about Nameko?
Nameko!
Maybe it's still a bit tricky.
I like it, but it's a bit difficult to eat a lot of them.
But to set the score right, when it comes to the chocolate snack, we like... Neither.
Yeah, you know it's chocolate.
The actual veggie is yummy.
I prefer to have the actual vegetables.
No chocolate.
No snacks.
Got it!
Understood.
That is the end of the BAKENOKO vs KINOKO debate.
The misunderstanding.
It's all cleared.
We can start our day knowing that it's all good now.
Well, today we wanted to introduce our first thoughts about Advent.
What was it like meeting Advent?
Moco-chan prepared something very special.
I hope you like it.
I did my best, okay?
First up, we have Shiori!
Our first thoughts of Shiori.
The first thing she said, I remember it very clearly.
She went, Shiori!
It was really cute.
So cute that I kind of thought like, is she joking?
It was that big of a gap!
It's very good.
Oh, right?
And then she was like really, really stoic and kind of like a bit of a hard to read ear to her, so it was a very interesting first impression, I think.
Very, very kakkoike.
Yeah.
I think to be completely honest, we were a bit scared of her at first, you know, especially with her really strong piercing bird-like eyes.
But I feel like, you know,
It was a bit of a funny feeling at first, you know?
We felt a bit troubled actually because we wanted to get to know Shiori better, but we just felt like we couldn't.
Like, really like, we're like, uh, FUWAMOCO what are we doing wrong, you know?
We would kind of think of strategies, you know, things to get her to maybe warm up to us.
Or us to warm up to her.
Right?
You know, she was a really tough book to crack, but all of a sudden, that just changed.
And we don't feel that way anymore, you know?
Shiori's really, really sweet.
I think she definitely tries to put on a strong face, like, I'm so cool.
But she's actually really, really sweet.
And even I feel like a bit shy sometimes, too.
She's really dependable.
Dependable!
And she has so, so, so much knowledge in that.
We wish we could Google search her brain.
Right?
She has a lot going on in her noggin.
So, it'd be nice to search it, but... You can't do that.
Yeah, we don't really want to overburden her with all our FUWAMOCO questions and requests and stuff like that.
Yeah.
Ah, and that's the other thing, you know, if the other Abyss members, if they let us be needy, right, we're gonna be needy.
It's not good.
They need to not spoil us.
We love Shiori!
We love you Shiori!
We hope you make Moco-chan jealous.
I did my best.
I really captured your eyes.
I think so, I think so.
Ruffians, what do you think?
Does it look just like her?
It does, right?
Adorable?
Thank you!
Next album member is Biboo!
I think one of the first things she said was, I'm really shy.
But that lasted really for about 30 minutes.
I don't think she's that shy.
Maybe she's shy like us.
Maybe.
Do you think we're shy?
I think we're shy.
Yeah.
Maybe we're the same kind of shy.
But she's very cute and a very sharp rock, you know?
I think she kind of downplays her powers.
Yeah.
You know, that makes her a bit cuter too.
But we can see through that.
And I think she's really a master of her craft.
Yeah.
I mean, she's had years and years and years
FUWAMOCO!
She's definitely the gamer.
I think there was one time where there was a reference that she wasn't a gamer and Biboo got kinda grumpy.
She's super sweet and super cute and you know, she just...
We get this really, really strong feeling that we really need to protect her extra hard.
Even though she's always smiling, she's strong.
She's probably fine.
We worry about her, so we want to make sure she's smiling too.
We feel very protectable.
We're protecting her smile too, sorry.
I was thinking though, you know... Biboo has her little flaps, right?
They look kind of like ears, but... And like, Biboo can fly too, right?
So I was thinking that... I don't know if Biboo can do this, but... It'd be nice to kind of fly together with Biboo's flaps.
And then like, our twin tails could go like... Yeah.
We can fly as a group together.
I guess with Nerissa too.
Shiori can just ride on the back.
Oh really?
I was gonna say we'll make her walk.
And then Biboo's song cover, it actually makes us really, really emotional.
I was listening to it for...
That's Biboo.
Biboo.
Next is... Fuwawa doesn't mince words.
What did she say wrong?
What, what, what, what, what?
Did I say something wrong again?
Are we gonna have to have another misunderstanding corner for the next FUWAMOCO Morning?
It's just gonna be a regular corner.
It's gonna be a regular, right?
Oh well.
And last but not least...
Nurrisa!
Nurrisa, you know, she's out of heaven.
She's definitely the lady that's not afraid to share what she's passionate about.
I did a good job capturing your likeness, right?
She has lady lips, right?
Yeah.
Now I'm kinda shy.
But you know, Nerissa, she also has a bit of a baby-ness to her.
Yeah, she's a lady baby.
Lady baby.
But of course, she has an amazing singing voice.
You know, sometimes she'll... Sometimes?
All the time!
She says, like, I'm not very good, you know, because of my horn issue.
Her horn's horny.
It makes sense, I guess.
Yeah, you know, and she causes damage to your mind when she starts singing and stuff, but...
Imagine if she didn't have her horn broken, then we'd all be done for.
She has her horn damaged and yet we're all still smitten.
Addicted.
I don't know about you, Ruffians, but...
Have you been able to get Love Me Love Me out of your head?
Because I know that... I woke up and it was just the... Give me your love!
That's all that's in my head!
So, it's no good.
Lifetime Showtime is competing.
It's competing.
Oh, they're rivals.
Yeah, it must be Nerissa's demonic powers, right?
The other thing that comes to mind, I think, the first impression, Nerissa really likes to be physical with us and the other element members.
I remember when we first saw her, it kind of looked like she had made Biboo her toy.
Tiny toy.
They were like stuck together.
Probably against Biboo's will, but Biboo was just smiling.
And then, there was one time, suddenly I think...
Just suddenly, out of nowhere, Nerissa just Kabedon'd me!
Very casually.
My first Kabedon, I tried really hard to have a straight face, but inside I was panicking.
It was too casual.
It was too casual, just all of a sudden she's just like, heh heh.
Yeah, I was surprised.
Have you ever been Kabedon'd, Ruffians?
Maybe...maybe we'll have the opportunity to introduce you.
I'm sorry.
Are you sure?
I was trying to be strong, but inside I was like... You liked it though, didn't you?
No, no, no.
Nerissa!
Me!
No, no, no.
Nerissa.
I wonder what was going through Nerissa's head.
What was her motive?
Maybe she wanted to just make you flustered.
Maybe.
And then I did the perfect thing.
I just had a straight face.
No reaction.
She did enjoy it, fine.
I'm safe.
The other thing about Nerissa.
Her legs are very pretty.
Especially when she crosses them.
It was hard not to stare.
But I made sure you know, I made sure to compliment.
Because I thought, maybe that might make Nerissa happy.
She seems the type.
What?
The type?
What does that mean?
The type to like those kind of compliments.
It's a nice compliment.
If it's a nice compliment, you say the compliment.
Right.
But yeah, she always is really helpful.
And you know, thinking about all the other avid members.
I was really kind and it's like a big bird that you can count on always.
A big bird.
A big bird you can count on.
It's important to have a big bird you can count on.
I'm not nervous.
Thank you!
I wonder, Ruffians, if your first impressions of the other Abbot members are similar to us.
Let us know with the hashtag FUWAMOCO Morning, okay?
Now for today's new corner!
It's Doggie of the Day!
Today we have... De-den!
We have this cutie!
He's the Doggie of the Day!
BAU BAU BAU!
You know, he's very strong.
Guard dog goals, I would say.
Look at his nose, it looks so good.
It looks like the PlayStation controller.
The PlayStation 2 controller!
I wanna touch it.
What is his name though?
Should we give him a name?
Let's give him a name then.
He looks like a fluffy to me.
But he looks fuzzy though, like his nose.
Give me a fuzzy.
A fuzzy?
Fuzzies.
A fuzzy.
That's his name now.
Should his name be fluffy or fuzzy?
Ruffians, what do you think?
Is he more fluffy or more fuzzy?
Fluffy or fuzzy.
What a dog, right?
Right!
Dog goes!
Very beautiful.
Fluffy.
Fuzzy.
Fluffy PlayStation.
This is a dog, not a PlayStation.
Wow, buzzy.
We'll call it buzzy for now.
But I wonder what his bark sounds like.
You know, he looks very royal.
Yeah.
So, you think it'd be more like a roar?
BAU!
Like a bower?
BAU.
A bower.
Yeah.
I kind of feel like it'd be maybe a bit more like... BAU!
BAU!
Like a kind of like a husky softness?
Oh, like a deep, a deep bork sound?
Deep bork?
Maybe.
Yeah.
Do we give this fuzzy royal guard dog, do we give them a rating?
I think his rating is he's a very good boy who loves you a lot.
We have competition, Moco-chan!
Gotta do our best.
Do our best!
Thank you for the Doggie of the Day!
Remember, we're always taking more doggies of the day, so please send us some!
Thank you!
And our next beginning of another new segment.
Today, I went for a walk.
I went on a walk.
On a walk.
Well, let's see what was this walk like.
Here's today's submission!
This looks like a very beautiful walk.
You know, all the clouds look so fluffy, but the blue skies, the grass is green, the trees are lush.
Very peaceful for your heart.
I hope it wasn't too hot, but you know, I think the cold tea probably helped a lot too, right?
You know, sometimes when we go on walks, we get really, really thirsty.
So sometimes as sort of treat, we'll get one to share.
Right!
You know, tea is a treat.
But it really is a treat.
It's a treat.
It's tea!
But it's good to stay hydrated, so make sure you always drink lots and lots of water.
And sunscreen too!
Be like with Koicha as well.
Yeah, Koicha's good!
But yeah, sunscreen, and watch out for cars, okay?
Cars, yeah.
Safety always.
Make sure you're always making sure that you're safe in your environment, okay?
Yeah, yeah.
Thank you!
And next, a sudden addition of a news segment.
We have Question of the Day!
De-den!
Quite a good question.
Is there anything you would like to try when you visit Japan?
Wanko Soba.
Soba is buckwheat noodle.
Wanko Soba is like a dish from Iwate Prefecture, but it's really just small servings of soba noodles in your bowl, and so you eat that, and then there's a soba keeper that will give you a new bowl, and then you repeat.
It's kind of like a bit of a race.
Yeah, they're smiling, right?
Yeah, and Wanko Soba is kind of like a feeling, you know, it's like you're a dog and you're really hungry, you know, so you gotta eat fast, fast, fast, fast, fast!
Eat!
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum!
We've never tried Ranko Soba before.
I guess we don't really like being watched while eating because we get nervous.
But we'll do our best to eat lots.
Like good puppies, okay?
And then afterwards, you know, you can count how many bowls that you eat.
Yeah, you can do it with your friends too, right?
How many bowls do you think he's eaten though?
Oh, uncountable.
But Ruffians, have you had Soba before?
Yeah!
Do you like Udon or Soba?
Yeah, Udon or Soba.
We're talking about wanko soba, so I feel bad if I don't say that I like soba the best, but... You can eat 70?
Soba.
Udon.
Moco-chan, let's both say it at the same time, okay?
Udon!
It's different.
But I only like, I like udon when it's really nice and chewy.
I like that udon too.
Right?
Sometimes there's like a thin udon and then I'm like... It's not what I was thinking.
But it's good too!
Soba's good too though.
Soba's one of my favorite in Japan.
There's some really really good soba places too.
I like to be able to have like fresh udon too, you know?
Yeah!
There's lots of yummy things.
But, but, but!
Next!
Our next stream, we will be playing Boki's Jump Scare.
We thought it really looked cute.
It's like a cute scary, right?
Yeah, we were preparing.
It's a jumpscare mansion, but you know... It's cute.
That's just one kind of form of horror, right?
So we opened it up and it already jumpscared us.
We had to both look away from the screen and then...
FUWAMOCO-chan was like, ahh, maybe not now, maybe I can't do this anymore.
I didn't want to close off the game because I thought it was going to jump scare me again.
Yeah.
When do the jump scares happen?
When do they stop?
I guess that's the point of a jump scare, right?
I hope it's more cute than what I've experienced so far.
Yeah.
So, we'll definitely need your help.
We need your help.
You better hold our paws, okay?
Yeah.
But even though you know it's a scary game, we're really looking forward to it because we want to play a game with you so bad!
We want to play a game!
We've been really happy to be able to chat lots and lots, but I feel like...
We should play a game sometime soon too, you know?
We'll be playing that later today, so we hope you'll be there, okay?
Today!
Not tomorrow!
Can you, as a punishment, can you say somewhere in your best Ina-senpai impersonation?
Tomorrow!
I give it a B+.
Ruffians, what do you think?
Rate Moco-chan's tomorrow.
But remember, Spooky Jumpscare Mansion is today today.
10 out of 10!
C-!
C-.
It's good to be honest.
And before we end today, let's have another peek at our schedule.
How about it?
Let's begin our schedule!
Don't forget, our first Advent collab is coming up.
Our first game collab.
I'm really excited about it.
I can't wait to be able to be there with Shiori and Bijou and Risu again.
I feel like it's been too long.
I really miss them.
We're gonna do our best to protect all of Advent.
It's gonna be a bit scary, but we'll do our best!
Actually, recently, I've been feeling a bit...
I don't want to share them!
It's a funny feeling.
Maybe it's not the most positive feeling, but... We have to share them now.
Yeah, we're not gonna keep them away from you.
They're free.
That's okay.
We're free.
And also, we have our first karaoke stream at FUWAMOCO Rock n' Rawr Party!
It's coming up on Saturday.
Are you excited with us?
We're very excited.
I don't know if you're excited.
Is there anything you want to hear us sing?
I'm always curious, you know.
It's our first first Welcome Party, so I want to make sure that it's good.
Good set list.
And finally, do you notice the question question question mic?
What is it?
It's a good mystery.
It's a mystery.
But you have to be there to find out, so make sure you're there, okay?
Yeah.
Well...
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Viewers today.
Ruffians, are you ready?
Kiyo Kiyo!
Ashita Ganbatte!
BAU BAU!
KSHMR!
Zokko!
BAU BAU!
Tomshi!
Nino!
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there,
I hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!